[Música]
hoy en directo va Vamos a cabo Cañaveral
en el estado de Florida donde continúa
la preparación de los últimos detalles
para el esperado despegue de la misión
artemis 1 la primera versión de esta
serie que en 2025 busca devolver al
hombre a la luna conectamos con alto
nivelchi enviado especial de Franz 24 a
cabo Cañaveral Anthony Cuál es el estado
de la misión Cuáles son las últimas
pruebas que se han realizado y cuál es
el ambiente en el lugar teniendo en
cuenta que este lanzamiento se va a
producir de madrugada
pues qué tal Muy buenas noches aquí en
el centro espacial Kennedy hay una gran
expectación los ingenieros están
confiados en que esta vez sí la misión
artemis pueda salir desde la plataforma
de cabo Cañaveral a la 1 y 4 de la
madrugada para siempre enviar su viaje
hacia la luna el lanzamiento sea
pospuesto hasta en cuatro ocasiones
primero por fallas técnicas y después se
tuvo que aplazar por el impacto de los
dos Huracanes Ian y Nicole en Florida en
cuanto los problemas técnicos desde la
Nasa aseguran que todo está bajo control
que ya se arreglaron los problemas en el
motor número 3 y en el sistema de
refrigeración en la última revisión que
tuvo lugar hace unos minutos ya se dio
luz verde y a menos de que haya algún
contratiempo de última hora el cohete
saldrá rumbo a la luna un proyecto de
Gran envergadura en el que además de la
NASA también participan la agencia
espacial Europea y otros socios
internacionales aseguran que será un
paso histórico para la industria
aeroespacial no solo porque se vuelve a
la luna
daños después de que se hiciera con la
misión Apolo sino porque este primer
viaje marcará un antes y un después en
las investigaciones para establecerse en
un futuro en Marte justamente ya usted
lo estaba mencionando se puede
considerar un hito esta misión
Pues si se considera un hito porque es
el proyecto de aeroespacial más caro de
la historia se ha construido el cohete
más grande y más costoso que jamás ha
ido al espacio el cohete sls tiene una
altura de 98 metros Lo que equivale a un
edificio de más de 30 pisos pesa más de
84 toneladas y en la nave orión podrán
viajar hasta 4 personas es efectivamente
un hito Porque no solo se pretende
volver a la luna sino lo que se quiere
explorar es la capacidad que tiene el
satélite para que en un futuro la luna
pueda convertirse en una especie de
estación de servicio permanente para los
viajes que se hagan a Marte por eso en
esta primera misión de artemis artemis 1
como se le conoce oficialmente el cohete
orbital alrededor de la luna Además está
previsto que la cápsula orión viaje aún
más lejos que en los años 70 llegando a
64 mil kilómetros de la cara más lejana
de la luna Este primer viaje es una
prueba de es un viaje sin tripulación
con el objetivo de analizar el terreno
para luego en dos o tres años poder
enviar de nuevo
humanos al satélite aunque no habrá
seres humanos a bordo en el interior de
este gigantesco cohete Irán 55 kilos de
artículos utilizados por los astronautas
del Apolo 11 y 3 maniquíes uno de ellos
como homenaje al ingeniero mexicano
Arturo Campos que jugó un papel clave a
la hora de rescatar a los astronautas de
la fallida misión de Apolo 13 se estima
que no será hasta por lo menos en 2024
cuando un ser humano regrese a la luna y
Se volverá a hacer historia porque Se
enviará a la primera mujer y a la
primera persona de minoría étnica